la camaro c'est elle le coupé sport qui
a fait vivre et mourir l'usiné gm de
boisbriand une nouvelle étape
la chaîne d'assemblage de general motors
ouvre en 1966 on pense alors que le
québec peut devenir un grand du secteur
automobile gm ni par angers 1
c'est un colosse un monstre de
l'entreprise trente cinq ans plus tard
au début de l'automne 2001 l'arrêt de
mort est signé par la grande patronne de
jane canada ja on a appris par les
médias
c'est ça le respect de la jam avec les
royals du québec ya douze à quatorze
automobile en ontario
on continue à favoriser l'ontario c'est
justement à l' usine d'oshawa qui est
finalement produite l'impala pressenti
pour sauver la chaîne de montage de
boisbriand en 1999 quand des savanes
peau camaro et firebird les voici les
modèles qui ne vendent pas assez sur
lesquels usine à miser pendant les sept
dernières années pour pas se cacher
actuellement ce qu'on vit celle à
l'abandon la disparition totale de
l'industrie de l'automobile
au québec la dernière voiture fabriquée
à l'usiné gm de boisbriand est sorti ce
matin de la chaîne de montage ils
avaient besoin
mais j'ai vu des larmes coulaient
dernier avec ottawa québec avait déjà
injecté de l'argent pour sauver les
usines et aurait pu encore tendre la
main
on est prêt à tours à faire ce chemin là
avec jm mais pour aller vers des
résultats mais j aime ne sera plus qu'un
souvenir à boisbriand bientôt remplacée
par un centre commercial ainsi mathieu
prost radio canada montréal